dix associations se sont réunies pour
les parents et les enfants de la ville
de trappes qui ont pu re découvrir
autour de jeux et de témoignages la
convention internationale des droits des
enfants autour de la table les jeunes
discutent entre eux et liste leurs
droits les écrits libre vide droit
scolarité et protection les enfants ils
n'ont pas de droite on a droit à tout
j'ai droit à être respectés
[Musique]
j'ai droit avoir un prénom et un nom
mois plus tard j'aimerais faire un
métier chirurgienne je suis très
impatient de lors d'ateliers les enfants
prennent connaissance de leurs droits
tout en s'amusant même si la convention
des droits des enfants fête ses 30 ans
certains endroits ne sont toujours pas
respectés il ya encore beaucoup de
progrès à faire
parce que il ya encore des enfants à la
rue alors qu'ils devraient être logés
avec leurs familles
il y a encore des enfants qui échappent
aux mailles de l'éducation en
particulier dans les gens du voyage en
particulier et donc il y a encore des
progrès à faire au niveau de la santé
aussi certains enfants ne sont pas bien
soigné un forum qui permet de donner la
parole aux enfants mais aussi aux
parents qui rencontrent des difficultés
au quotidien des associations de
défenseur des droits qui luttent pour
avoir des aides pour les enfants
défavorisés abandonnés ou handicapées